hey what is up you Bacchus Animax your
animal roar and I am an American the
lead
no one point for me cut off I got it
and glad to be stop interrupting baka
Bor Red Cafe the new episode live with
some cool people debating the best tune
dinner in anime you guys know I'm a
sucker for tuned to this is gonna be fun
we got here with me
NOx Taku it's not like I want to be here
anything baka yeah there he goes there
he goes okay it's not like I like rad
cafe or anything vodka mmm I choose not
to use it because we're keeping track
and I am confident that I'll get my Bach
is in next industry and of course we got
ours what's up man it's not like I was
excited to be on this or anything back
hell yeah guys so basically you're in
for two hours with these innuendoes so
yep make the best of it bracket link in
the description to the Twitter also we
created a Red Cafe special channel on
YouTube so be sure to subscribe to that
link in the description also we're gonna
be streaming on Twitch Ren cafe in the
future so the anime opport which we're
gonna be using for now link to that in
the description as well subscribe to
those guys because [ __ ] is happening
[ __ ] it's not like that have it's hard
to the rad you fail and it was lured to
ego or anything okay you're really
pushing that man you're right why do i
Josh don't need donated ten Canadian
dollars to legalize cannabis Canada's a
great place he said today is a man to
say thank you for having a moto got
three character in this bracket
you're welcome says the person who made
the bracket and came up with the money
got to carry everything thank you to
Knox and all you guys
teching Briggs everybody thank you for
holding Koran cafe down while I was in
Europe it was hectic over there
different times on it stuff so I really
appreciate it guys did you guys did you
just get it back recently or how long
have you been back then two days two
days okay so just still kind of like
jet-lagged and all that good stuff
oh yeah that's always fun when I got
back from Florida I was like aw crap
YouTube cuz you know you keep your
videos consistent but then if you leave
it just you gotta get them back up yup
yeah yeah Europe is six hour difference
oh gosh yeah I was at least in the same
time zone
anyway six hour difference then so
basically when it's you know like six
here it's twelve four for me so I feel
like tired out like six seven in the
evening time but okay let me know guys
when you want to start because this is
gonna be fun we got a lot of soon dares
how come there's no mail soon Aries on
here a male can be a tsundere yes yeah
dragon and I knew slime anime this I
actually I messaged you I said should I
include the dragon from the slime anime
me yes we all we also think you know we
have bother you hey like I actually look
up to you or anything
baka oh no okay please no it has to it
has to make sense contextually that's
gonna be the rule no it did I counted it
you can't just keep like rattling it off
but it's fine we got this alright
alright Bacchus who's gonna name off the
characters on the list okay well the guy
who made the list
oh I hate that okay so the first round
are we all ready yeah ready Perea the
[ __ ] goddess from food wars I assume
someone here watched food wars decide
for me and Briggs
but if collide the first two episodes
lock down I got this okay versus how do
i Suzumiya from Haruhi Suzumiya no
relation I feel like imma be very sad
for this for the specific matchup
because adding now is like one of my
favorite wife Ruth of all times by a
hundred percent vote for her who isn't
like a competent cinder it right thing
is stronger than the main protagonist I
haven't seen food Wars yet as much as
Knox wants me to and I have not steered
you wrong thus far but but how do we
Suzumiya is the female Lord Twigg Oh
with all her godly powers so our Lord we
go to a mere godlike high relie Suzumiya
I'm gonna go with arena because I've
only seen the first episode Wars I have
read a little bit more than the manga I
remember seeing some clips of her and I
kind of get what she's about so I'm
gonna go with food wars on this one I
did not think this would happen I just
gave a middle finger to my camera even
though it doesn't work even though your
opinion doesn't matter low art who are
you voting for the Lord really bad first
round for you well I'm okay with that
because I've only actually I've seen a
bit of food Wars but I haven't seen
Haruhi I'm perfect I'm not a true weep
you know so this is actually good I'm
proud of you not true we've who covered
yeah what is it now you got a watch like
ten shonan's and twenty harems to get
your weeb card in the mail I think
that's how it works yeah yeah
why do we guys blop blup said george twe
go into chat it's a thing I don't know
why to think but it's a thing yay I'm so
sad it's a thing it's not a thing I said
that George Joestar you're the first
Joestar that we meet is actually Lord we
go in disguise Canon was actually gonna
be the main character of part 9 George
he's coming back I talked to a rocky the
other day so you guys are pretty dead on
read that I'm pretty sure he's actually
Oda in disguise okay that's just twee go
section there because if it actually is
Oda then it actually makes sense
whereas if he was Lord we go
would not make okay no exaggerations
here I have absolutely no idea when you
mention tweet I have absolutely zero
arts we go Lord
okay I'll bow to his greatness I just
have no idea who he is
okay well one day I will explain it to
you but today is not that baby another
day okay yeah all right so food Wars
wins food porn beats hiring Suzumiya
much to everyone's surprise Oh
greens are coming out that's it burns
burns yes was he saying boo-boo we were
Paramus Simpson nerd so that's something
else yeah oh yeah oh yeah great our next
round next round it is Quirino from my
little sister cannot be this cute versus
cheeto gay from Nisekoi that's a real
thing what what's the name of that first
anime again my little sister cannot be
that cute clearly a light novel yeah no
no no it's a lifestyle
mention of existence it's beyond a
lifestyle it's what make it's what's
making anime popular in the West okay
okay I just got to go with that because
how do you beat that
I mean that there that little sister is
pretty cute I got I'd never have sisters
but you know sure I don't have sisters
either but I feel like if I did I would
be pretty grossed out I haven't seen
this one so I'm gonna we have an
adventure scene advantage although I am
a sister I think I think I get like an
even I get like a free pass whoever
doesn't have a sister cuz we could talk
about all we want and it doesn't really
sound creepy because we have no
reference points but you you're on the
chopping block on this one low art oh
yeah yeah so I usually you know I'm
gonna use my my card to just just stay
away from that one I guess you vote for
cheeto gay then yeah absolutely
absolutely buy Depot
they hear here so I vote for cutie no
easily because she's a sick character
even though she's from an anime called
my little sister can I be this cute I
mean I like nisekoi and I personally
think you know a second best girl in
Nisekoi however did I just say the wrong
characters name whatever I don't know
these characters so a little sister one
yeah well it all it's a hilarious Joe
and since I actually like Nisekoi I'm
voting for Nisekoi girl I don't know her
name I don't remember wait
does it turn out that the little sister
girl is like an axe murderer cuz I do
not trust her face eyeball belly he's
actually a thug life gangster uh I need
to watch this now yes it's actually
hilarious
yeah this sounds great aren't all
sisters thug-life gangsters though or am
i complete we didn't know yeah I just
have a brother and he's also an animator
of like me yeah alright so awkward
silence yeah honestly I didn't watch the
other one that's what no one ever
watches the shows daily next what do you
mean what do you mean this is a recon
show you know that's a recon show is not
a recon show okay it's already contro
it's a little bit of recon show next we
have rin tohsaka
from fate/stay night your choice of
which fate/stay night you want
first is senjo gajala whose name i
pronounced possibly right it's got to be
central good ha ha I'm just gonna throw
that out there right away and we lost
taking okay I died there for a second I
don't know what the hell happened like I
missed you or anything baka expert usage
yeah so ridden is I think the far
inferior waifu to save her from
fate/stay night so zephyr is way better
what are you very inferior
she's inferior you just saw Nathan
superior my back saber has no
personality
did you watch the original face day
night yes see Madea is the best
did you watch the original fate/stay
night much Maria
I watched okay well that was the route
focusing on R in the river Sina focused
on saber and sabers best girl in
fate/stay night
I've been watched fate/zero zero didn't
focus on a love root fate/zero was just
all round ten out of ten awesomeness
that everyone should watch because she
carries around the ton of scissors yes
i'm or rin tohsaka because a lot and
also centric ahead it does not shut up
damn it
I'm going for I'm going for Rin
balls-deep gadzooks it's all the
embarrassed by me Bacchus is it all up
to me once again do I know you I mean
don't make the wrong choice though I'm
sorry it is like a new year to saber but
like I'm gonna focus on unlimited blade
works since that's when she gets her
time to sign to shine and as a cinder a
I think she does a pretty good job so
I'm voting for her yeah also talking in
chat said they'd have to win red have to
win for like night read half win also
I'm just noticing there's a lot of has
anyone else seen back I'm gonna go three
oh absolutely I love that John so the
truth is revealed oh yeah this makes
sense when you have it won't watch
PowerPoint the anime yet we can't expect
you to understand Oh what is it I'm
actually watching quis Amano got that
Evo well yeah let's not start from the
first season great idea
to be fair they tell the whole story on
old are there monsters yep
I actually I I was told to watch the
PISA mother with me first
I think it was the first novel or
chronologically or some talk about
gayatri's the first and she's in the
first episode of the first season of the
first show of the mana got three
franchise but that's not actually the
first
on a logically right now we're in
getting into a nerd battle drown in true
weeb style Josh donated money to
complain saying
Sanju Gahanna is arguably one of the
best female characters ever and she lost
what the [ __ ]
thanks Josh call me Josh the almighty
word of Josh we're looking at some data
characters who are defined by the sue
minimis of their character rather than
best girl Hall time if it was best girl
of all time
that obviously darkness would be on this
list oh yeah whoo thank you for
introducing me to her as well because
that was fun Suba is an underrated
masterpiece and that's why the next
bracket tournament bingo it's aqua from
Kona sua
who is varied tsundere vs. mean a or
mine however you want to pronounce
what's different in the Devin sub me
maka Tommy got kill I don't mean watch
those but listen does aqua actually
count as a swinger because does she
actually like like yes yes yes I mean
I'm voting mean a before we whenever she
gets scared she goes full casimir I look
like dependence I don't know if she
liked actually or if she's just kind of
like Cosimo's my [ __ ] kind of thing
right I think it's the other way around
I think I caught fire the cinder is she
just not as typical or like textbook as
the other ones you know she's sort of
subverts the trope a little bit yeah
like I mean I love aqua like I can't
knob more for aqua but I'm just I just
want to like clarify because yeah to me
it's like all of Kona subbaiya in all
these tropes on purpose but yeah I gotta
go with aqua I mean just her the the
skirt she wears goes well the thing is
DNA from a kind of get killed she is my
favorite female character and economy
got kill I think and I vote for aqua
hands down because Conan super
underrated masterpiece well constant was
amazing but doesn't mean she's an
amazing cinder a
the other girl even though I never talk
was on screen I am throwing a party wait
a minute is it up to me now no wart okay
well no pressure no pressure but you
will be judged by every single nerd when
you come up with your answer both of
these shows and I'm okay with being
judged by every nerd I'm confident in
saying aqua Oh
I've sent you oh I clap I clap for you
there you can are so good people
by the way Steven Alvin don't donate it
$9.99 to say where is Vegeta and to that
I have to say is we're just looking at
girls cuz yeah we need to do a male
version of this later I mean yeah we
could you know with window in my opinion
be better than me though cuz every time
I do something like 21 best boobs and
bleach or one-piece I'm like I'll do
like a best ABS in one piece I never got
around to doing it you got to do this
man's don't have the same incentive I
know I don't
I need to get like a girl co-host on
here and then we can get this going or
something scary for me because when I
see one of teching 's 21 best boobs in
one piece I'm like who's the sad sad
with one boob the teching had to pick
anyway I think you may play the first
person or bring up that reference so I
guess me and ox think alike to answer
your question it was Domino but let's
continue hey man
pirates they're always fighting should
happen anyway okay anyway next we have
cootie sue from steins gate vs. Astana
the lovely maiden from sword I dunno if
machi sakers who doesn't win this and
yeah I mean this [ __ ] stream she has
so teri stamped across her forehead
yeah may I begin this I believe that
while asana is definitely gets wounded
at first she's very briefly at some data
and
then goes full Kirito so I would agree
with that yes I have yes I have to go
with machi said cuz she is just such a
kind of through and through to another
character oh he's nice it's really nice
you have to come up for with tons of
reasons why you would vote for cooties
do-over asana but that's a monastery
make this like a like a believable
stream man this is the Red Cafe it's not
a believable stream cootie su is one of
the best wife who's in all of anime
she's a sick tsundere I love her also
not if you maintain bracket clearly Lord
wriggle is rubbing off on him and he was
mocked if occurs with him go all the way
you're caressing right now sorry do you
have a car su na body pillow you're
caressing right now I wish I did
don't we all don't we all Cristina she
is not only a great Dre but in her story
she is integral she is the perfect
counterbalance to oka BAE's madness
without her the story doesn't work to
say I want to just shout out dizzy bro
series finds gateway road cuz it's
terrible it's pretty bad
I still like I like the characters but
like it's no I mean dizzy bros videos
are terrible
no I kind of agree with this first video
I don't I think I design it was so good
I liked it wasn't that good man I don't
think it compares to the original but I
think great I think I have an 18 well I
kind of got to the end iam like so that
was all pointless and then I'm like oh
the beginning didn't matter at all then
I don't know I wasn't as into it I still
like because okabe rintarou
I haven't seen you stop like a son of a
[ __ ] sorry I would see this video but I
will say that George edge yeah right -
George like we know your real name isn't
George - ego and it's official rank up
there running out of ideas
jokes a new buddy we've never had ideas
we haven't cracked 100 episodes yet
that'll be the next one right I got 98
or 99 yeah ok ok so we got two more yeah
and that's when we officially go full
PewDiePie and ask you for ideas yeah
that'll be the worst brackets ever
imagine the fanbase coming up with the
break yeah just just come to me every
week I could probably spit ball some
best kneecaps in anime best on left
forearms in anime I mean it would really
get real not gonna lie I was considering
to do best right hands of anime best
Kingdom's obviously best awkward oh yeah
I'm gonna Brooke has to be included in
there I mean Corey and the house
automatically gets the best awkward
boner anime just how about we how about
we do best bracket so you just take all
the a bracket sand minimize them on a
bracket it'd be bracket ception oh yeah
I'll be crazy by the way Andrew asks it
says he wishes that we would made this a
podcast we can listen to it without
having YouTube opened we hear you we're
working on it stay tuned
also YouTube premium the girl says
knucks are you doubting our skills I'm
not doubting your skills I'm expecting a
full rank if a bracket of like 16
characters with hashirama cells
[Laughter]
what is Bungie gum do again but not one
incredible move that they've never
explained in all I am actually doing a
video about it it's happening now I've
been infected with the Mimi's it can't
you can't you have a hankering for Mimi
is that nothing can satisfy oh damn oh
damn caster for life says should have
had Jericho on this bracket so true
totally for God's above jerk if you
wanted a loser get down and be
completely irrelevant regolith spade a
spade who here would you kick out for
Jericho you actually know why don't you
know one that I didn't know okay that's
gonna make this way easier um the food
Wars chick but she's putting so but I'd
there's many on here I've never even
seen the anime of but I have at least
that's
fair really yeah it's not better Asuka
is not better I think that is great what
girl confirmed my video to find out what
awesome
turquoise awesome read the manga [ __ ]
Jericho did nothing in the manga she's
never done anything ever bond sacrifices
everything and he's like half dead and
she can't even carry him away the woman
who with her rival hello go and throws a
boulder and she's like oh I will block
the boulder and it beats
are you laughing successors Jericho if
anything you're just making sure it'll
sound better you scum oh so now is it
okay scene with you still donate more
money just say can we do best say use no
or one of the rank of pays I don't know
man a good idea
we might I don't think we already know
the do say a wind so like Oh obviously
hasta is a call sir do you know I take
it back all might say you ins do you
know why hmm why the same point to that
voice actor the voice is all my voice is
like we go oh I certainly didn't know
that
alright next round we have Colin Kousuke
from Code Geass vs. winry rockbell from
food him into the attic you mister they
do okay okay I'm going I'm going with
winter on that's what is the correct
Japanese I'm going with wintry on this
one because she's like a real-life kind
of soon Gary a little bit you know it's
not overly exaggerated too much with her
it's pretty realistic but she does have
that quality after that with full
colander okay
I think I thought when we was I thought
it was a weak character yeah for once I
think I think winner is a fine character
I like her but Colin is awesome and the
reason I love Colin is she's never had
some that it but she's not defined
solely by her like romantic feelings
like many tuned today and like other
characters in code yes like surely Colin
is defined by her drive to fight for
justice and right the wrongs that the
Bretagne have gone on to the Japanese
people and she's in a bunny suit once
say oh I forgot about that
that is why she's in a bondage scene
every two episodes yeah I remember that
poor she's in the shower the bondage
scenes kind of overrode the bunny scene
okay I think everyone knows that calm is
hard it wouldn't be guys but yeah so
just she has like strong motivations
that I agree with him respect she's
driven by a desire for justice so I have
to go with my girl Colin
whereas when Reese just holding her
boyfriend's hand the whole show but
she's supportive well or lack thereof
she's holding her boyfriend's hand
whether it's attached to him or not Oh
does anyone else want to vote to one
right now stick with Winry I like yeah I
like fullmetal as a special spice in my
heart
same here but you know why food I feel
obligated to vote for her I've never
felt so much to a wrench in my life I
cannot believe we're gonna lose this one
anime over yeah superior tuned aray are
we doing an upset
it's Briggs I know you hate us I know
you don't tempt me so lord whatever he
gets evil his jokes is twee goes down
lor you voted for a winner
uh-huh well I feel obligated to but you
know what I think I'm actually gonna go
with uh with Code Geass with think I
will
I would erect your entire day it's over
Oh remember this is not a judgment on
the anime just on that soon there are
qualities of one character ya know on
the character not necessarily the
Sundari qualities well anyway our next
round we have taiga the character who no
one expected to be on this list
yes vs tornado or Tatsu matter from one
punch man
one punch I mean that's so much he is
obviously hotter but I just feel like
taiga is a more developed whoa dude
whoa never mind thank you buddy
yeah character to me so I go with Tiger
I gotta go tatsumaki she literally like
she is like a like when I think of a
tsundere character
Sundari character she is the first
person I think of it's like she's it's
it's tangible it was just awful
taiga is the first thing I think really
hey
but yeah tatsumaki I gotta go with my
girl on that one yeah the only lolly s
character I've ever really been
attracted to I say esque cuz she's
technically she's 28 but she's okay I
know right I know right not over a
hundred she still had him fit yeah
that's right every lolly has to be at
least a thousand or two oh okay by the
way someone apparently donated $5 and
then retracted their message so I don't
know what's going on redacted yes oh by
the way where's Noel on here damn it
you're right
you are right I mean she wouldn't win
but I don't know she does she uses it as
well kiss your friend Oh cousin girl is
best girl
Oh mimosa mimosa mimosa
I could go for a tall drink of a mimosa
right oh oh well I would anyone else
like to venture their opinion who who
voted here you
/ tatsumaki - because I actually don't
like taiga Oh No
navel nerd donated $5 to say God bless
the palm top palm top tiger being tiger
come on guys
rip palmtop tiger I'm so happy that I'm
the third vote for tatsumaki I did not
know again I thought she was a bit
annoying - she's an angry little monster
yes and she's a great character and I
love toradora but one punch man is the
king that's not what we're debating she
is a sick character I laughed so hard at
the end of the first season well the
only season so far rip so at the end of
that season when like she approaches
Saitama to see how he destroyed the
whole ship and whatever and Jenness is
like making this face saying that oh
little girl go away you don't belong
here and just slam the [ __ ] wall
saitama's like cheering him on on the
back did she just wrecks him and he oh
it can think it's way more soon Gary
later on even in the webcomic it's it's
pretty intense yeah but it's actually
pronounced toradora and tatsumaki okay
that's that's nice congratulations on
being that guy that's super cool you
know
looks like someone is butthurt also the
egan 101 wants to see our anchor free
debating anime that are better in
english so you want to see a rank of a
debating ghost stories and nothing else
[Laughter]
Stein's get yeah I'm thinking of ghost
hunt stories there's the scene oh this
is the best scene ever there's a scene
where they visit this guy who approaches
this cat and he like says to the cat
what have you done the cat's like I
won't tell you and in the English dub
this kid goes not me yeah anyway because
for
kids anime would win anyways one piece
in the finals huh no but in all honesty
best dubs bacchanal hands down really it
does have a really good one ya know best
actual dog is cobweb Bebo yes definitely
a good second place after bacchanal just
because of okabe rintarou like whoever
dubbed him was a genius and actually
made his character matter in my opinion
I'm gonna throw I'm gonna throw in
Hellsing Ultimate as it's a really good
english dub because they they like
because you know that's British it takes
place in London so they gon like British
accents and stuff it was pretty yeah
next round we have Kyo from Planet vs.
Oscar from Evangelion I'm going with the
purple haired chick I've seen neither of
these have fun oh definitely
you're taking you're making the right
decision because she's also [ __ ]
where's Kyo oh okay well I have not seen
um where was the atom in the first one
head clinic everyone hi so I'm gonna
obviously vote for even jelly on your ID
the weird thing is I've listened to the
soundtrack of Clannad but I've not seen
the actual show oh god man you gotta see
it because with that soundtrack you'll
be crying every four minutes okay not
everyone is the level of manliness that
you are yeah it takes a true man to cry
like a [ __ ] watching combat role i dude
the Clannad was ass it was only after
story that was amazing see that's a
problem I dropped it three times I've
cried exactly two times in my life to an
animated program once was for them
Futurama episode where Fry's dog dies
and the second one was an episode of
elfin lead
I couldn't bear a baseball anime I cry
for Adam all the time every time I
rewatched Gurren Lagann I cry like eight
times but like I might have actually
cried more than that but those are the
two that actually come out of an
epicness
Hunter hunter let's it's kind of scary
for you because like I hear about people
crying and I'm like picturing like are
you talking about like tearing up or eat
a single tear
would be like super epic and manly and
just like your ever left my eyes
watching something well you are a
monster psychopath last time I actually
felt tears welling up was the latest
episode of fairytale it was so good to
have it back
anyway next I vote for ahsoka hands down
sociopath Shane Dawson's gonna yeah
that's my own dogs
yeah Shane Dawson did you see his last
video today he kind of didn't need to do
any of the other ones aside from this
last one but so if you want to watch it
I mean just watch really I might I might
I might check this out just because I'm
interested in the topic but I usually
don't watch him now although it's good
like all sure its covariance defining
yeah not my thing but you know whatever
the thing is okay we don't need to get
into that I guess yeah it's too - oh boy
oh boy it's the random guys time first
day jitters okay yeah no ask her this is
the star yeah so no offense but oh yeah
maybe the red shirt yeah ask her
concerns me deeply she is a concerning
character because she might be had seen
through a but I think she might also
have borderline personality disorder I
don't I don't want to deal with that I
mean the show is about like trauma and
how that's involved in it so I'm going
with the other one she oh yes daddio so
not right what if I told you
Kyo has a crush on the person that she's
trying to set her sister up with no
that's just that's just a decent human
being thing to do right that's normal in
an OVA Kyo herself ends up with the guy
yeah with the OVA is like ultra-reality
but the point is that Kyo knows that her
sister role likes him so she tries to
set him up even though she likes him too
because she's awesome and in addition to
this a person with the most British name
ever all they were Oliver wiglesworth
who did a stream yeah for your donation
in British pounds that's like probably
$80 why is that not a thing yeah yeah
well anyway he always victorious
I don't mind cuz I like Yoshi's second
best girl in Clannad I'm like Nagisa
who's worst girl in Clannad what you I
mean this injury that I like best girl
in cinder is best girl is uh
what's-her-name Tomoyo
I think that's her name oh oh the crazy
one that beats the crap out of everyone
yeah I like your girl that takes
everyone else's ass okay thank you but
moving on to round two of the bracket of
Awesomeness we have arena who actually
beat how do i Suzumiya which is still
scary versus Cheeto yay from Nisekoi
yeah Tina's going all the way boys she's
got my vote and I gotta go I'm gonna go
for her - yeah Knox loves it so much
that I'll take his word
whatever baka yeah I kind of forgot
about that yep
I didn't well I did I'm Ibaka all right
off it well in any case the two like
faces of tsundere Archie toga and Tyga
and they're both eliminated how scary is
adding as clearly the superior sin today
like she's a perfect sin today that's
all so unreal and like matters to the
story yes unreal unreal
no way
it's it's the surprise in your voice
anyway so the next round we have Rin who
just barely beats and yoga Hara because
of default reasons and you guys disturbs
me versus aqua from Kona Suba oh okay
does anyone remember Kona soup is full
name because if you do that'll be very
impersonal subarashii sekai no streaky
fugu all gonna blow you all away and
actually say that but pigs Congrats
yeah we'll just go for awkward cuz I
love her so much
I love her too I don't but cheese is
hilarious that's one thing about Kona
Suba is all three of them are best girls
they're all so I love all three of them
if I've had to write then ago oh they
were ranked girl darkness aqua tag team
would be amazing I don't care for mega
me at all
I love mega man it would be meant for me
megaman aqua darkness no I know because
your plug not on me man oh culture
whatever you say man but I vote for aqua
too and that's the point both of our
sacred favorite ramen from Kona supa
every metals and darkness is best girl
but go closely brother don't aqua and
all the girls are great but I'm just
gonna put my irrelevant vote right now
to rin because he's actually a send
[Music]
Rigsby got center a here with the system
Baca rocks talk whose choice of aqua
well she's a good character she's barely
a cinder a and course it was better than
fate/stay night but like heads down
that's not gonna contestant contribute
to my vote I'm sorry
anyway she wins next round are we good
yeah we're good yeah we have cooties do
versus Colin Colin dice lifts [ __ ] you
come on Sakura zu let's call it
yes amazing she's you know she has
principles that she fights for risks her
life for she's an amazing fighter she
does so much she's so hot
he say developer [ __ ] I'm Ryan and
then she's like I'll sacrifice myself to
save my URI mind I'll sacrifice myself I
don't know I'll leave it like that
my URI my mind URI you bozo do you want
my URI my you she oh I I thought we were
talking about my ODU [ __ ] plants my
URI from Bleach okay well I mean I guess
he is kind of a soon I mean are you
gonna vote for someone who had that
technologic guy things back you
top-loading for me you're both voting
for the Queen well it's not like I like
your vote or anything pakka okay it's
back to being a racehorse gentlemen all
right so I think whoever votes for Colin
over Maki say is clearly draining the
power of steins gate definitely needs to
rewatch it and just lost my you know my
respect and all their tastes as far as
whamon yeah ramen if either of you had
the chance to sleep with either of those
two women you would all pick Colin you
lying scum Wow I'm in this for the long
haul
hey guys body pillow it would be cursive
damn are you saying that Gregory is not
all about fictional sex with fictional
women because if it's not that I don't
want to be part of this there's no
fiction of whamon I don't know what I
was been doing here the last like six
times I've been on I know I know I'm
talking about eScan or who's gonna bang
is gonna anyway thought about Kurisu
who's clearly superior to Colin I'm
ashamed to be ashamed talking about what
are you talking about call is barely a
cinder a to call she is she and like I
said she is a patriot who fights for
what's right and risks everything it has
to play have a double life we get it
cook yeah you're safe beforehand and man
you're always gonna pay for everyone and
cookie us well I guess I could
who is just a scientist just a scientist
moving who cares
perturbed by climate change they
wouldn't even have met if it wasn't for
scientist thank fate that is true all
right tacking who you're voting for
Colin [ __ ] you oh you of course of
course no question there's no debate
here man if you've seen Stein's get you
vote for cootie suits so basically you
have I've seen Stiles get you club face
have you seen steins gate zero no I have
not have you watched steins gate within
the last three years I don't remember
what I saw it but the point is it's too
long and adamak our team truth and
justice and ice our team el psy congroo
team annoying poopy panthers stalled
you know something animatic would come
up with with his superior taste could be
pants Mickey if this was the best
villain bracket I would definitely have
poopy pants from Captain Underpants
oh yeah not about that character yes
which guys I know she can't be part of
this because it's not animate but
objectively the best tool there of all
time is tough from Avatar The Last
Airbender she isn't a me well yeah I
mean you can't I can't deny that yeah I
love topped off with my favorite
character growing up she lose to at
least five characters on this list I
take it back she would only lose to two
for me oh I think you'd lose to like two
or three so yeah that that means it's
pretty good not an anime nowhere near
cooties leveled mind you monkey sick
goes through it's an incredible
injustice and friendships were lost but
it was worth it it was worth it
okay we have
hatsue machi hatsue Miki samake tornado
bimbo vs. kyo I'm gonna go with tornado
bimbo on this one there we go
I will also look at the bit look or NATO
I'm gonna go with Kyoko's like again
that's the monkey in the first season
doesn't get that much time I haven't
read the mommy yet so I'm gonna go with
you
fair enough Lord yeah it's a debate
right now because I keep thinking about
that scene I think there's saxophone
music in it when the main character in
Kyo are in the tool shed or something
yes in the best scene in the whole first
season of Clannad and it was yeah that
that scene almost had me laughing in
tears
so I guess what you think he thinks he's
John alike so I I think just based off
that I'm going with her yes good man
glad it was a 2 2 just so I could pull
it away from poor Animax grasp and vote
for it too - Miggy what you want me to
put my tutu on McGee's a man of culture
Oh clearly could I haven't watched yet
finally taking advantage of that for
once usually I have the obscure shows no
one ever heard of TI association guys
it's coup de Naga Cheops is my Aki are
you sound like a dubbed version t otsuma
Bellanca Animax favorite characters
because if not let's go down a list and
just attack v-dub ticklin ed is hell
yeah maybe it's one of the reasons I
never watched it voice actress by the
way she's like the worst of all of them
I swear I got two episodes in like 3 or
4 times
mm-hmm don't watch the dog now watch the
first season how could I know you have
to watch the first season but but I
don't wanna I don't wanna do it if only
someone would make a Brit a video
abridging the first season of
if Hawley mother's basement would have
done this anime cheat sheet on Clannad
instead of on JoJo's which is absolutely
watch yeah yeah yes no need to see that
well good thing interact cafe because
this is the place where I convert fellow
youtubers to watch JoJo's like everyone
else on this stream I'll make it really
simple for you guys I'll make it really
simple for you it involves zombie
vampires at the beginning that's all you
had to do to get me to start reading it
yeah that's true actually you know won't
say I hear that then you can't turn away
from it so hard by the time you get to
the 3rd season there is no more zombie
vampires well there's one but we don't
talk about him but I mean like at that
point you're already hooked if you're
gonna be hooked you know what I mean
dude are you watching part 5 right now I
am yes
be honest it's amazing
did you just do you have the ability to
echo your voice whenever you want I know
right right the first two episodes of
JoJo's part 5 Anna Mac is ibaka well I'm
still finishing part 4 hold on yeah I
haven't well that's the thing is you can
start part 5 without finishing part 4 so
that's what I'm doing no well I'm
breaking the laws of the universe I
guess Baca animals anything why you have
to have a life for like I started shows
us after you and I finished before you
well it was hard and your hope to keep
up with stuff guys it was hard but
anyway I just want to say that also out
of principle he ran cafe anything that
mother's basement says we disagree with
so he does what we couldn't include
tough because avatar is not an anime
fight us no art who's working on like a
12 part series on Avatar
oh it's gonna kill me I'm gonna die well
as long as you're all well a frickin
Legend of Korra i I don't after they are
playing sports for too long I didn't
know what to do
am I the weird one I really liked Korra
I feel like I get like a sniper scope
put on me every time I say that but I
really like that [ __ ] show
Hey hey he dead he dead no but the thing
is if you I don't know maybe you stop
watching out for season one in which
case what you're saying makes sense but
otherwise I don't know what's up I've
seen all four seasons I still love it oh
well that's just strange maybe I have
brain maybe have a brain tumor I should
get that [ __ ] you're great okay all
right it has problems with it I'm not
gonna claim that it's it's it's
problem-free but overall I thought it
was a great sequel to the city dude I'm
not gonna lie to you now but it will
definitely make you more comfortable and
rank fa my favorite anime going on right
now after Joe Joe's is easily fairy tale
oh that's beautiful
I Love You Man it's so sad it's so sad
goes to show what else is going on
anyway but goblins lair yeah I like
goblins lair almost as much as fairy
tale yeah anyway there there are more
issues and goblins later though impaired
than in fairy tale like everyone harps
on fairy tale for its issues and it has
numerous issues but goblins lairs a
world where they send fifteen-year-old
kids to die kind of like our world
unlike our world without 18 year-olds
but you know close close enough depends
on the country that is true yes this
isn't Wakanda here anyway next we have
made it so far and only you got her back
she's still in it but she's reeling
ladies and gentlemen right and she's up
against aqua herself okay aqua literally
can't do anything and Adina is the
strongest character in the entire series
so [ __ ] fight the entire series she's
stronger than clearly could be the woman
who's gonna go down that rabbit hole
from
do you think better than frequency Red
Cafe misogynist though maybe no an
exposed video not I was ashamed to be on
this walk here I'll cook a Dina can
out-cook arena I don't think anyone can
I can are you kidding she was number 10
on the elite 10
oh that's that that doesn't mean she
couldn't defeat everyone else well she
could have beaten eysan coz eysan sucked
yes i won
well haven't you yes you haven't read
the manga anyone kind of defeated better
Aaron I can make me a better sandwich
but I prefer aqua as a character kind of
needed to survive I still think that
Joey cheeto is like the best cook in
food Wars obviously it's okay under the
students JoJo's part for yes
JoJo's part for would win this bracket
for best tsundere yeah just the whole
show the whole damn show man don't you
just love us in that I could kick your
ass I'm like JoJo's yes tsundere yandere
mixed together in that beautiful blend
yeah so I vote for Edina and adamak
votes for aqua and I'll go through aqua
I don't know what Joseph his mother is
but I want her Holly no not show skit
now that stroke I forget her name the
only show more misogynistic min rank of
a yeah kind of yeah
the funniest thing is like part three
everyone has stands and they're like
killing everyone he was a stupid baby
understand Joe just Joe throws mother
gets his pen and it's killing her bear
there are women including sexy women who
have stands yes oh yeah Mariah magnet
girl I love that
girl steamer she made her boobs huge
like I just stuffed a bunch of like nuts
and bolts in there I'm like [ __ ] boy
yeah that's one of the funniest scenes
in all of Jojo
I love shows like reactions like mm-hmm
he's attached to have the land yes like
like try to slide off him yeah I love
that some of that fight
anyway it's due to I vote aqua easily AK
was amazing all right finally yeah I've
got a I got a breakup like I gotta do
this again
well I'm happy it happened because I
would not be able to decide between Maki
say and not inna there's my two favorite
tsunade's for sure I'm going with her
Irina Wow I've seen enough of I've seen
enough of food Wars that I think she's a
better Sundari
Wow I mean not wrong I'm not ready is it
Makkah versus tatsumaki now yeah I was
saying that those are my two favorite
but I think lo are brought it for a Dina
over aqua or over Maki say where that
the hypothetical over aqua okay so that
means arenas in the finals no oh three
of us voted for Eddie no way we need
more people to watch food Wars bridge
she she cleared it yep I don't know how
we that's like me no she's that good and
we know you're watch this [ __ ] like I
said just from the few clips I've seen
I'm like I know what she's about
yeah I've only seen nine it was the
basic idea for tenderizes you know that
they you know they hate the character
and they developed eventually like the
character but they think opposed do not
do it as well as food wars did for Erina
they give us a tsundere as a cake it's
the same basic recipe for each one you
know flour eggs milk but but it's that
little extra thing that makes it special
now we're comparing women to food
products just any that would bake the
[ __ ] of it
that applies to male officer dairies of
course of course
well Vegeta would win it all Regina
would be the best cake that's what is
super say bargain sale
you were supposed to say that I know
anyway next round we have Mikey say
cooties ooh vs tattoo McKee zenimitsu ma
Calaca Ukiah Takaaki before nato bimbo
how dare you even say her name she
shouldn't even be mentioned in the same
phrase as much I'm a FUBU ki fan a
hundred percent but I mean tots and
marquees here's I guess I just got all
right Wheatley no way you're really a
fan of Oh her massive boobs yeah that
but all I was gonna say respecting one
oh yeah that goes without saying but
fubuki has nice boobs too
thank God the majority of your fan base
is male yeah anyway it's so funny though
cause like I think what what percent of
your fan base is male
it's like eighty-nine percent for me
come on it's like 95 to five whoa yeah I
think that's your eighty eighty percent
yeah well you come here seasonal stuff
it's like 15 percent female but anyway
guys we would like if you respect women
well like this video right away of
course I already liked it and if you
don't respect women well then don't
leave a like Wow the like button shame
on you don't leave a like [ __ ]
hey I just said that man it was leave a
like you're anything who what's the
award gonna be when they win this all go
to their house and beat the crap out of
a visually bad for rat cafe forever
someone mentioned me cus uh
from magical index she's a good student
today that I did not finish magical
index I did not get very far
magical index yeah and like I had it on
the list and I ended up chucking her
last minute for actually tatsumaki
because I think you made
this far Tatsu about to lose the cooties
do cuz I vote cooties new best girl but
of course
oh yeah oh this is the demo this is a
democracy even I who thought college
would win would vote for moccasin but of
course there we go it's all I've ever
wanted
alright so we're in the finals I will
rock I will ride tornado people addy not
a person only two people on the stream
even know who it is
no everyone knows who she is she's that
infamous just don't really know who she
is anyway it's arena the [ __ ] goddess
from food Wars versus cootie sue best
girl of the bracket science the science
[ __ ] Christina all time I vote for
cootie sue with ease
I vote for zombie do you know who that
is is it which from what Samuel and
Sango Cory wasabi disco neither its
massive cursor it was hard for me but
Knox accuracy was like my number one
waifu number two ish who's number 1 mu
Ferengi of course and actually no how
could I even ask and Andy's ethnic
number 3 but what's what's wrong with
you in discriminating is well-endowed
women yeah what is with that Wow Wow
well clearly I like strong independent
women because they are all very
competent in their own series unlike the
other synthetic imbeciles I'm in a make
a video called like the complex feminist
politics of rant cafe you use like
various schools cut to me wearing a
fancy suit sitting in a chair like for a
documentaries like you know when I first
joined rank cafe I had a feeling
there's like a fireplace behind me my
little caption comes up at the bottom
and I'm just talking sipping some
whiskey
yeah he's convinced shame us and that
were sociopaths just within the read
we've been talking about anime girls for
the last hour and a half I think we all
are but wait
Hayden more donated $2 to say where sue
you from MH eh I don't really think
Sue's at something I don't think there's
any truth from the Naha that's why I've
never really thought of many of them
like really anybody in that series like
that yeah yeah they all had powers to
take their clothes off that was pretty
impressive maybe maybe in Class B the
one chick with the big fist chick no
kendo no kiddos not a tsundere
no not right now but maybe she time she
the seedling of a tsundere flower may in
fact blossom one day CI flowers not too
cake well actually now we're getting
into this idea I discussed in my
feminist politics class the other day
pocketable deflowering shame on you yeah
thank you
there you go took the words right out of
my mouth I can't win welcome to 2018
it's almost over for cootie sue it's
already 2-0 oh yeah Curry's the wing
screw you guys sorry Annabelle
I'm not gonna vote for Marcus ikutsu
because I'm voting for Christina there
we go and lower what's your vote is it
all five yeah you know who it is
you know what smack you say also known
as a fifth tint
yeah maybe a system I need to re-watch
Stein's wins for best tune that I am not
unhappy with this I just remember being
massively confused when I watched it the
first time Colin is still my girl but
yeah I know I'm donated what I can only
assume is check Crona its shackles
but yeah we went continue not funny at
all back up alright maybe we should
should I run the tallies up now on all
these toys alright who do you think won
it was probably Briggs her dogs okay so
just ignore my drawings of the Triforce
in the yin-yang symbol there and knucks
did cinch it with 10 followed by me with
7 anime uproar 5 Briggs 4 and then I
only got one from you lo art maybe yeah
that was purposeful I didn't want to
contribute to the south edge into the
entire time so there might be yeah I
feel like Briggs deserved second place
there might have forgotten a few there
took the high road yeah he really did I
want to say before we wrap it up and
other than the fact that in the
description you will find the link to a
special rank of a channel that we're
gonna be starting and also the anime
port which so subscribe to those because
rank if they will eventually be moving
to those yes well very good so nice to
talk to Harry you know people know I
stick some things I just want to say
that I respect women and so do my fellow
brother and joining me today yes us
brother indefinitely agree respect women
as well most women mind you clearly
respect women as we just talked about
that I'm not gonna be able to pronounce
this word correctly for the rest of my
life now
I already get okay no it's a real
problem it's been said that way so much
that I've heard that in class sometimes
you raise your hand and you're like
hello I just want to talk a little bit
about the wham em and they're like okay
I would ask if he was mentally okay
regardless cuz there's just like who
does that like I would like to talk
about wham and please Josh Josh this is
a geography class right now
I like the Bob's and the Virg Anna but
Dinah I think my first like feminist
type of class this semester and I'm just
not gonna say anything
yeah I never took any of those bro
well I took a history course I didn't
realize it was like gonna be like
anything related to sociology gender
studies or women's studies is going to
be like very far left I did take a
sociology class when I was in Community
College it was taught by she was like
probably like 2320 probably like my age
right now and she was pretty heavily
feminist and she in class ones she made
a joke about tying a rubber band of my
dick and having it snap off I can't
remember exactly yeah this actually
happened we all laughed at the time but
thinking back on it now I probably could
have talked to somebody about that yeah
yeah let's just say in the first class
we all had to say our preferred pronouns
that's how intense it was oh yeah I
think I think my dick snapping off is a
little bit more intense than that but I
know I always say you know that's very
important because my preferred pronoun
is his imperial Highness and I do enjoy
when people refer to me as his imperial
Highness Tom Tom Tom Tom so let's enter
a cafe while we're still ahead sorted
well knock stop hi I didn't hear what
you said but hi I said as graceful rival
like says
as a ruined knocks dog yes yes that's
what they say
so no no final words guys we're all done
we're all up if you like avatar or team
Titans to anime that aren't really anime
go subscribe too low art thank you sir
yeah just thank you for having me on it
was really fun I I really appreciate it
it was a good time it was a pleasure
having you on and you were quite a fun
guy to hang out with oh yeah you run guy
it sounds like he's close to saying it
but he doesn't each time and I can
commend that all right all right well
thank you guys for joining again
everyone's links are in the description
so check everyone out if you haven't
already teching is juggling something I
love it until next time which is
hopefully next week see us space cowboy
Pham crew outside I missed you